[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
buscamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados tras los
devastadores efectos de una pandemia con
la mira en la recuperación económica y
con la guerra como telón de fondo
'francia ir a las urnas para su elección
presidencial cómo funcionan estos
comicios quienes compiten por llegar al
palacio del elíseo y cuáles son las
preocupaciones de los votantes cerca de
48 millones de franceses están llamados
a las urnas el próximo 10 de abril para
elegir por sufragio universal directo
quien gobernará el país los próximos 5
años aunque teóricamente alguien podría
ganar en primera vuelta obteniendo la
mayoría absoluta todos los sondeos
auguran que habrá balotaje este se
celebraría el 24 de abril todos los
aspirantes tenían hasta el 4 de marzo
para cumplir con una regla muy
particular debían obtener por lo menos
500 avales de cargos electos algunos
esperaron hasta el último momento para
inscribirse otros estuvieron a punto de
no calificar y otros sencillamente se
quedaron por fuera es el caso de la
aspira de izquierda y cristian tu oveja
la exministra de justicia en el gobierno
de françois hollande fue la
incontestable ganadora de la primaria
popular una especie de elección interna
no oficial de la izquierda sin embargo
no logró los 500 avales y tuvo que
retirar su candidatura fueron 65
precandidatos al inicio pero el 7 de
marzo el consejo constitucional comunicó
los nombres de los 12 candidatos
oficiales entre ellos manuel ma con con
44 años el actual presidente centrista y
proeuropeo busca la reelección algo que
ningún candidato ha logrado desde
jacques chirac el candidato de la
república en marcha lidera las encuestas
a pesar de una presidencia marcada por
las protestas sociales la pandemia y el
conflicto en ucrania tres candidatos son
los más opcionados para impedirle
quedarse en el palacio del elíseo por un
lado imagine lepén del partido
reagrupación nacional la política de
extrema derecha con un discurso
antiinmigrante y euroescéptico compite
por tercera vez a la presidencia tras
ser derrotada por el propio mccall en
2017 también está riquísimo este
comentarista de televisión en se
convirtió en otra opción de la extrema
derecha con su partido bautizado
reconquista mantiene un discurso
enfocado en la seguridad y una feroz
retórica en torno a la identidad
nacional y al rechazo tajante a los
flujos migratorios e incluso ha sido
condenado por incitación al odio racial
la derecha más tradicional del partido
de los republicanos ha puesto por
valérie pécresse fue ministra durante la
era sarkozy y se hace llamar el la dama
de hierro francesa y se define también
como dos tercios de angela merkel y un
tercio margaret thatcher su discurso
ante la migración se ha endurecido en la
contienda y las encuestas indican que de
llegar a una segunda ronda p que sería
la única de estos tres políticos que
podría poner a mccall en serios aprietos
la izquierda llega dividida y debilitada
su mejor esperanza está en el veterano
jean luc mélenchon fundador del partido
francia en su misa
con dos dígitos en las encuestas figuran
también el ecologista yannick jadot y
han hidalgo la alcaldesa socialista de
parís veamos también cuáles son los
temas centrales para los votantes el
poder adquisitivo es el asunto por
excelencia el 52% de los franceses se
muestra preocupado por la inflación así
como el aumento en los precios de
electricidad gas y los combustibles
motivo de descontento social es que ya
en 2018 impulsó las protestas de los
chalecos amarillos la guerra en ucrania
pasó de la noche a la mañana a
convertirse en otro eje de la campaña la
sociedad se debate entre sí brindar
apoyo militar a ucrania o sea abrirle o
no a ese país las puertas de la unión
europea un conflicto que podría terminar
por beneficiar a makro en las urnas por
su rol de mediador la ecología la crisis
climática está sin duda en la mente de
los votantes en medio de catástrofes
ambientales a nivel mundial la evidente
dependencia de los hidrocarburos y las
promesas de una ansiada transición
energética
y por supuesto la inmigración un
espinoso tema que reaparece con fuerza
en cada ciclo electoral ahora ha
reavivado por la crisis de refugiados
ucranianos frente a los flujos
tradicionales de emigrantes provenientes
de áfrica y de oriente medio y por
último otros dos puntos importantes en
esta campaña la financiación y la
aparición en medios de comunicación para
la primera vuelta el tope de
financiamiento es 16 8 millones de euros
por candidato y 22,5 millones para la
segunda en cumplir esta norma traería
consecuencias legales para los
aspirantes en francia- los medios de
comunicación se rigen por estrictas
normas que determinan cuánto tiempo al
aire pueden otorgar a los candidatos una
vez iniciada la campaña el tiempo de
aparición debe ser el mismo para todos
así las cosas arranca la cuenta
regresiva para una batalla política que
definirá el rumbo del país que es uno de
los ejes centrales de la unión europea
si les sirvió el vídeo para entender las
claves de las elecciones en francia los
esperamos en otro episodio en cinco
minutos en france 24 y france 24
puntocom